how much uh technical difficulty is
there with the programming like what
programming language you were talking
about what was zero i'd like maybe it
was hard for us but um i mean we
there was nothing the only thing that
was complex about instagram at the
beginning
technically was making it scale and we
were
just plain old objective c for the
client uh so it was iphone only
yep as an android person i'm deeply
offended but go ahead again come on this
was 2010. oh sure sure sorry android's
getting a lot better yeah yeah so
um i'd take it back if i were to do
something today i think it would be very
different in terms of launch strategy
right android's enormous too uh
but anyway um back to that moment it was
objective c uh and then
we were python based uh which is just
like this is before python was really
cool like now it's cool because it's all
these machine learning libraries like
support python and right
now it's super
now it's like cool to be bothered back
then it was like oh google uses python
like maybe you should use python
facebook was php like
i had worked at a small startup of some
ex googlers that used python so we used
it and we used a framework called django
uh which still exists and people use for
basically the back end and then
threw a couple interesting things in
there i mean we used postgres which was
kind of fun it was a little bit like
hipster database at the time right
my sequel my sequel like everyone used
my sql so like using postgres was like
an interesting decision right uh but we
used it because it had a bunch of uh geo
features built in because we thought we
were going to be checking out pretty
much it's also super cool now so you
were into python before it was cool and
you were into postgres before it was
cool yeah we were basically like not
only hipster
hipster photo company hipster tech
company right uh we also adopted redis
early and like
loved it i mean it solved so many
problems for us
and turns out that's still pretty cool
but the programming was very easy it was
like sign up a user have a feed there
was nothing
no machine learning at all zero can you
get some context how many users at each
of these stages are we're talking about
100 users a thousand users so the stage
i just described i mean that technical
stack lasted
through
probably 50 million users
um
i mean seriously like you can get away
with a lot with with a pretty basic
stack like i think a lot of startups try
to over engineer their solutions from
the beginning to like really scale and
you can get away with a lot
that being said most of the first two
years of instagram was literally just
trying to make that stack scale and it
wasn't it was it was not a python
problem it was like
literally just like where do we put the
data like it's all coming in too fast
like how do we store it how do we make
sure to be up how do we like
how do we make sure we're on the right
side boxes that they have enough memory
um those were the issues but can you
speak to the choices you make at that
stage when you're growing so quickly
do you use something like somebody
else's computer infrastructure
or do you build in-house
i'm only laughing because we when we
launched we had a single
computer that we had rented
in some color space in la i don't even
remember what it was called
because i thought that's what you did
when i worked at a company called odio
that became twitter i remember visiting
our space in san francisco you walked in
you had to wear the ear things it was
cold and fans everywhere right
and we had to you know plug one out
replace one and i was the intern so i
just like held things but i thought to
myself oh this is how it goes and then i
remember being in a vc's office
i think it was benchmark's office and i
think we ran into another entrepreneur
and they were like oh how are things
going we're like uh you know trying to
scale this thing
and they were like well i mean can't you
just add more instances and i was like
what do you mean
and they're like instances on amazon i
was like what are those
and it was this moment where we realized
how deep in it we were because we had no
idea that aw aws existed nor should we
be using it anyway
that night we went back to the office
and we got on aws but we we did this
really dumb thing where
i'm so sorry to people listening but um
we brought up an instance which was our
our database it's going to be a
replacement for our database
but we had it talking over the public
internet to our little box in la that
was our app server nice yeah um that's
how sophisticated we were and obviously
that was very very slow
um didn't work at all i mean it worked
but didn't work did we only like later
that night did we realize we had to have
it all together
but at least like if you're listening
right now and you're thinking you know i
have no chance i'm going to start a
starbucks i have no chance
i don't know we did it we made a bunch
of really dumb mistakes initially i
think the question is how quickly do you
learn that you're making a mistake and
do you do the right thing immediately
right after so you didn't pay for those
mistakes by you know by failure so
yeah how quickly did you fix it
i guess there's a lot of ways to sneak
up to this question of how the hell do
you scale the thing uh other startups if
you have an idea how do you scale the
thing is this is just aws
and uh
you try to write the kind of code that's
easy to spread across a large number of
instances and then
the rest is just put money into it
basically i would say a couple things
first off
don't even ask the question just find
product market fit
duct tape it together right like if you
have to i think there's a big caveat
here which i want to get to
but generally all that matters is
product market fit
that's all that matters if people like
your product
do not worry about when 50 000 people
use your product because you will be
happy that you have that problem when
you get there i actually can't name
many
startups
where they go from nothing to something
overnight and they can't figure out how
to scale it there are some
but i think nowadays it's a when i say a
solved problem like
there are ways of solving it
the base case is typically that startups
worry way too much about scaling way too
early and forget that they actually have
to make something that people like
that's the that's the default mistake
case
but what i'll say is um
once you start scaling
i mean hiring quickly people who have
seen the game before and just know how
to do it it it becomes um
it becomes a bit of like yeah just throw
instances of the problem right
but the last thing i'll say on this that
i think did save us
we were pretty rigorous about writing
tests uh from the beginning
that helped us
move very very quickly when we wanted to
rewrite parts of the product
and know that we weren't breaking
something else
tests are one of those things where it's
like you go slow to go fast
and they suck when you have to write
them because you have to figure it out
and
they're always those ones that break
when you don't want them to break and
they're annoying and it feels like you
spent all this time but
looking back i think that like long-term
optimal
even with a team of four
it allowed us to move very very quickly
because anyone could touch any part of
the the the product and know that they
weren't going to bring down the site or
at least in general at which point do
you know product market fit how many
users would you say is it all it takes
is like 10 people or is it a thousand is
it 50 000
i don't think it is
generally a question of absolute numbers
i think it's a question of cohorts and i
think it's a question of trends so
you know it depends how big
your business is trying to be right but
if i were signing up a thousand people a
week and they all retain like the
retention curves for those cohorts
looked good healthy
and even like as you started getting
more people on the service maybe those
earlier cohorts started curving up again
because now there are network effects
and their friends are on the service or
totally depends what type of business
you're in but i'm talking purely social
right
um
i don't think it's an absolute
uh number i think it is a
i guess you could call it a marginal
number so i spend a lot of time when i
work with startups asking them like okay
have you looked at that cohort versus
this cohort whether it's your clients or
whether it's people signing up for uh
the service
but a lot of people think you just have
to hit some mark like 10 000 people or
50 000 people
but really
seven-ish billion people in the world
most people forever will not know about
your product there are always more
people out there to sign up it's just a
question of how you turn on the spigot
so
you